[Music]
I'm welcome to Hannity and also welcome
to Biden's disaster of America now
tonight Israeli soldiers they are on the
ground in Gaza battling Hamas other
units from the IDF they are clashing
with Hezbollah in Lebanon Americans and
hundreds of others they are still being
held hostage underground in Gaza a
network of 300 miles of underground
Terror tunnels to kill Israelis and to
take them hostage that is the war that
Hamas has been waging against Israel now
going on for decades now it's time for
Israel to win this war at the same time
we have US soldiers in Iraq and Syria
they continue to come under attack from
Iranian proxies all around the region we
have two powerful us carrier strike
groups that are now in the Mediterranean
Sea not far from Israel now keep in mind
this is your state of the world under
your President Joe Biden and another m
massive war still raging close by with
hundreds of thousands dead in Ukraine
and millions displaced and Joe wanting
to basically fight a proxy war with
Russia uh and not causing Europe to pay
their fair share back at home what's
going on here China is buying up Acres
thousands of Acres of farmland and Ranch
Land in our country and near US military
installations all while threatening uh
our allies and our soldiers in the
Pacific when they are not their spy
balloons Gathering Intel over our
military bases or confronting our
fighter jets in international airspace
or our Navy in international waters uh
well this is what the Chinese do and
they're getting away with it meanwhile
look at the economy inflation is through
the roof houses now are unaffordable
over 8% for a 30-year fixed rate
mortgage and in our country a level of
anti-Semitism outright leftwing bigotry
and hatred it is on the rise in a way I
never thought thought I'd see in my
lifetime and I doubt many of you thought
you'd see in yours and by the way have
you noticed the border is an utter
disaster under Joe Biden over 8 million
illegal immigrants will cross into this
country by the end of this year maybe as
high as nine maybe as high as 10 million
that is roughly the population of New
York City this is your state of the
union under Joe Biden your president
this includes by the way at our border
659 people from Iran why are Iranians
coming to our border 538 from Syria
along with thousands of other spe
special interest aliens from the Middle
East why are they coming here who's
paying for them to come in here uh why
isn't there any real vetting of the
people crossing that border because I'll
tell you right now the next 911 is
almost certainly being plotted and
planned from inside our country thank
you Joe Biden now to the Democrats
watching this program tonight the ones
that voted for Joe Biden I ask ask you
tonight are you happy are we not better
than this is this what you wanted is
this what it looks like when quote the
adults are back in charge because in
2021 it was Joe Biden who promised to
lower the temperature unite the country
he said our borders were closed and
secure they have lied to us again and
again and again but after three years of
nothing but weakness lying dishonesty
confusion from a guy frankly that can
barely speak or walk the world is
imploding and America America is even
more divided than ever weakness always
invites this kind of chaos but don't
worry because according to His Brilliant
Vice President Joe Biden is alive and
running for reelection he's actually
alive what a standard take a look we
were talking to some democratic
donors and they have told us that should
something befall President Biden and he
is not able to run that there would be a
free for all for who would run as
president you are in the spot that that
would be unnatural for you to step up
but we're hearing from donors that they
would not naturally fall into line why
is that well first of all I'm not going
to engage in that hypothetical because
Joe Biden is very much alive and running
for reelection so but you do know I mean
that is a concern and and a legitimate
concern I would say I hear from a lot of
different people a lot of different
things but Joe Biden is very much alive
well really is that his big attribute at
this point that's the standard that's
some standard the world is in turmoil it
is in chaos it is in disarray because
America has now abdicated its leadership
role on the world stage one main source
of that turmoil of course is the Islamic
Republic of Iran uh the country that Joe
wants to give billions and billions of
dollars to like after gifting the
mullers of Iran billions in Revenue uh
the administration doesn't seem to have
any plan at all to deal with the terror
that is Unleashed by Iran he helped Iran
get well basically richer than ever
because he eased up on their ability to
sell oil on the world stage take a look
and what's the message to Iran
don't as President Biden said just don't
exactly one word pretty
straightforward Joe says don't comma
says don't don't what you think you're
in good hands which is troubling to say
the least America and the world we are
now at a very critical inflection point
I'll tell you as just a political
Observer been doing this a long time
I've never felt a sense that things are
this dangerous and this out of control
not only for this country but for the
entire world this is not a conservative
versus liberal moment this is not
Republican versus Democrat either right
right now it's a battle between good and
evil Freedom versus tyranny uh and
especially religious tyranny
civilization versus terrorist brutality
that apparently a lot of people don't
have the moral Clarity to see just look
at the anti-israeli protest erupting not
only all across our country in the globe
you you know you don't see many American
flags do you unless they're on fire you
also won't see many peace signs but
there are a lot of posters for a global
antifa which is a whole holy war against
non-believers you will hear demands for
Israel to immediately call for a
ceasefire but you'll almost never hear a
bad word about Hamas the terror
organization instead you get signs like
this one in New York City condoning rape
and torture and murder of women and
children and even beheadings quote by
any means necessary now for weeks we
have witnessed huge rallies around the
world and around this country featuring
nothing but vile virulent anti-Semitic
rator work we've seen swas stickers
chance for Israel to be wiped off the
map calls for Jews to be annihilated and
they do all of this while pretending to
be peaceloving victims of Oppression
it's repulsive it's disgusting at
Cornell an ivy league university these
message reportedly posted on a
university Forum quote rape and kill the
Jew women Jews are the excrement of the
face of the Earth here's another quote
glory to Hamas Liberation by any means
necessary another quote if you see a
Jewish person on campus follow them home
slit their throats rats need to be
eliminated from Cornell now sadly we see
similar rhetoric from college professors
including one trans Professor apparently
from Chicago posting the
following Israelis are pigs Savages very
bad people irredeemable excrement may
they rot in hell look at this image
posted to the Huffington Post comparing
Jews to Nazis Gaza to aitz the
Huffington Post claiming that they
removed the image right away and disavow
the sentiment of their anti-semitic
message meanwhile a Nevada man was just
arrested for threatening to kidnap and
murder a Jewish US senator a Foreign
Service Officer will not be fired by the
Biden Administration and their state
department after this person called Jews
the enemies of God overseas it's even
worse in the Muslim dominated area of
Russia you have a massive Lynch Mob
storming a regional airport after rumors
that a Plane full of quote Jews from Tel
Aviv would be landing well they broke
into the terminal and the tarmac looking
for the Jews presumably to capture and
kill them both the Associated Press and
the Washington Post they just refer to
this as um a simple protest just like
the 574 riots in the summer of 2020
mostly peaceful well they they peaceful
dozens dead thousands of cops injured
billions in property damaged oh and no
January six style commission to look at
any of that and kamla Harris did tweet
out the fund the bail fund after the
police precinct of Minneapolis was
burned to the ground in turkey that
country's dictator erdogan holding a
pramas rally calling the terrorist
organization a Liberation group and now
erdogan and turkey threatening to join
their war against Israel
by the way turkey should immediately be
kicked out of NATO they do not share our
values and let us be clear here cheering
for Global Islamic war or praising a
group of Barbarians those that
intentionally torture and kill babies
and even behead them and burn them or if
you're calling for Israel to be wiped
off the map quote from the river to the
sea or spewing vile rhetoric against
Jews you are not a freedom fighter you
have sided with radicals that want to
kill and destroy if you truly want
Palestinians to be free maybe you should
be calling out Hamas that they be wiped
out because they are the ones that have
the power they are the ones that have
been killing Israelis they were
responsible for October 7th they're the
ones who Charter calls for the
destruction of Israel Hamas uses their
fellow Palestinians as human Shields
they steal much needed Aid and resources
to build these this these miles and
miles of network of tunnels uh they're
the ones oppressing women they're the
ones that have no problem killing gays
and lesbians they commit vile acts of
Terror against Israel and the people of
Gaza they're responsible for any
innocent death in Gaza and last but not
least Hamas does whatever Iran tells
them and wants them to do does this seem
like freedom to you now sadly so many in
this world have lost their way and lost
any sense of real moral Clarity case
Point our own Jennifer Griffin pointing
out can you guess who takes the chair of
the UN Human Rights Council on November
the
2nd okay I hope you're sitting down the
Islamic Republic of Iran the UN is a
useless organization goodbye to the UN
goodbye to the wef uh goodbye to the wh
get out of the Paris climate Accords
stop wasting our time and money they are
historically anti-American and
anti-semitic now by the way the same
country that just beat a young girl to
death in Iran for not wearing a head
scarf really the same country now
funding Terror all over the world hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else